on today's visual studio toolbox Chris
Woodruff and I are gonna start our
conversation on how you build web api's
[Music]
hi welcome to visual studio toolbox I'm
your host Robert Greene and joining me
today is Chris Woodward hey Chris hey
Robert how are you good
welcome to the show welcome to the cozy
confines my studio business is great
yeah it's intimate it's like there
should be a fireplace in here ya know
it's 90 degrees outside I'm not sure I
might do the fireplace right now but
come wintertime
that would be handy may you may Chris is
here to talk about Web API this is an
interesting topic so Web API is
basically the modern way of having
services running in the cloud that serve
up data typically right and we've done
this before we've had you know as a mex
web services and WCF and then there was
web api and which is you know restful
and we've been doing this for quite some
time
lots of way way back yeah yeah but I
think it's getting a little bit easier
to do and we're gonna look at creating
them using ASP core yep which is will
wind up being faster it was daunting
that core is really fast these days
we'll talk about how you create them
what they look like so if you're
somebody like me is kind of coming from
the WCF frame I've written a lot of WCF
services I have a bunch of existing ones
that I would love to turn into Web API
how do you build a web api what does it
look like is the plumbing the routing
and all the rest of that we'll talk
about that where you would put all your
logic what that looks like the benefit
of course of the Web API is that it
gives us our world where you have a
service running in the cloud and you any
client any client at all basically
passes it a string with a request yeah
the service reads that string goes off
and does whatever it does whether it's
written in whatever it's written in who
cares
and then packages up your data sends it
back as a string typically in JSON
format and there's really cool tools for
working back and forth between James
sharp if you're a.net developer if
you're not then you just get JSON back
everybody everyone can do right with
JavaScript right JavaScript problem with
WCF of course is it relied on soap which
is powerful but then you kind of had to
your clients had to have knowledge of
soap yeah and if your client didn't then
you would have to write that support
yourself who wants to do that web api is
just completely open and neutral so we
are leveraging the power of the Internet
yes so we're leveraging HTTP mm-hmm so
everyone uses HTTP yeah so we're
actually gonna leverage the HTTP calls
so so in a sense you hit the nail on the
head a string comes across but there's
also another piece of information that
comes across with it that would be the
HTTP verb right so we have to know if
just like sequel some people don't like
to talk about HTTP and Rast with the
sequel combination kind of the idea but
getting get is select yeah there's put
there's a post right is insert update
delete it's it's crud right whatever the
verb is so what I know I don't because
for people they're coming into the
restful world it makes things a little
bit easier to to show them maybe use
some of their knowledge that they have
from from T sequel and then they can
they can kind of understand to be a
little more comfortable in the HTTP
world so yeah
so it's actually really easy they have
made I mean the the asp.net core team
has made things extremely simple
all right so prove that prove it that's
a great segue into demos prove it prove
let's write ourselves a Web API
so we're gonna write an API that
connects up to it's not working there we
go
this is why the clocks hidden by the way
there we go that was strange
okay I'll pause a little bit so we're
gonna build an API against a database
that Microsoft created a number of years
ago it's called Chinook okay
you ever heard should not huh so she was
not a salmon in addition to being it is
I love the salmon but Chinook is a
database that has it simulates a online
music store mm-hmm the front and back so
I like it because I has a whole bunch of
like cool rock artists and albums and
tracks and it's much more interesting
than Northwind yes anything's were
interesting sorry I'm sorry but
anything's more interesting than
Northwind and bicycle parts so I'm gonna
use I'm gonna use Chinook and I actually
Chinook went away so I don't think
Chinook I have it on my on my github
mm-hmm because it was going away and
what's the old on no way I thought Dana
never dies
well it doesn't buy what's the old
complex so yes
Chinook used to be on coke Plex okay and
then it went down you can still get it
but no-one's updating it because
codeplex
can't be updated okay so I grabbed
everything and you can find it out on my
github very auditory myspace will put a
link to that yes so so let's do this so
it's really simple so start like
everything we're going to start with a
new project so we're going to go under
dotnet core and then we're going to do
SP dotnet core web app and I'm gonna
change over and let's browse because I
like to use I always put things in my
projects folder so and then let's just
call it
should knock core API pretty simple so
we're going to say okay we get the next
stage and this is going to be an API
we're gonna use asp.net core 2.1 and for
this demo just to make things easier i'm
gonna turn off HTTP you can leave it on
i mean you need to leave it on when you
actually build something for production
but to make this demo it's it's just one
less thing i have to worry about okay
and we're going to show you a public api
that anyone can use would you need HD
yes yes yes
because remember Google and with Chrome
and I think Microsoft with edge are
setting it up where those browsers if
you don't use HTTP you'll start getting
warnings or people accessing or API
well mostly web sites will start getting
warnings from browsers okay so it is
good to use HTTPS if nothing else it's
all encrypted between your API and the
who's that were getting it on any other
sides okay okay so we're gonna say okay
it's gonna stand up everything let it
kind of figure it out let it pull all of
its dependencies in okay so what I'm
gonna do to begin with is the project
always comes with some initial
controller and some initial logic I'm
just gonna delete that we don't need it
and then the other thing is is under
your project properties if you go to
debug you will find that there will be
an API slash values because when you
first launch your browser it wants to go
out to
that that controller that initially
created but we don't want that
controller ruined creator-owned okay so
I'm just gonna say API slash so let's
save that now we're that we're at a good
starting point so I have a number of
packages that I have to install and
again I copied them from a text file and
we're just going to bring that text file
in let me go grab that and so we're
installing all the packages that we need
for entity framework core okay so sequel
server sequel server design and then any
new framework core tools okay so you
need that especially when you have an
existing database that you're gonna be
generating your your models on right and
I like having I like using existing
databases I'm not really a code first
type of person that can does migrations
and stuff I'll I'm I was a DBA for a
couple of projects so I like having real
databases that are fine fully tuned and
that run well and have good indexes and
stuff like that I'm old fashioned I
guess okay so we have everything that we
need the next thing that we need to do
is we need to use a command called
scaffold - dbcontext and I'm gonna copy
this in I'm gonna paste this in and I'm
gonna explain what it is so it's a
command that will generate your DB
contacts and all of your entity models
mm-hmm so you give it that command and
then you give it your connection string
so I'm gonna run off of a local a local
database and I'm going to use trusted
trusted connection but then you have to
give it the type of database that you're
going to be using right so that's where
he comes in and the and you have to say
Microsoft dot and then the
we record that sequel server just say
I'm going to be using a sequel server
right if you're using Azure sequel use
sequel server sequel server and then the
last thing you need to do is give it a
parameter called output der in alpha der
is where you want all of your generated
code to be put and I just say - output
der and then space models okay and that
will create a models class in your
project and then it will put all those
new generated files out there so we're
gonna run that it takes a second to to
go through don't worry about that
sometimes you will have that if I run it
again sometimes any of the framework
core is a little funny with scaffold
dashdb contest so weird about this I
might have missed this part okay where
did you tell it what database you were
using so in my connection string if you
take a look here I have a server just
server dot oh okay and so that just
means the local the local running me
that it's and then I have a database
just called Chinook and then I just say
it is trusted connection equals true so
it's really simple but you can have a
little behind the scenes here I can't
really read that text yeah sorry I know
it's there and I can increase or I can
fix the resolution I guess me good
enough go ahead yeah so this will
generate all of your models so at this
point we have our Chinook context so
should be very familiar and so far this
is standard pretty standard stuff
representative cream work right from
anything right so it's pretty much the
same thing and if you know any framework
six you should know
99% of grant corps yeah so it's pretty
it's there's there's I will say core is
still a subset of in some ways a subset
it has some things that six doesn't have
but it has lots of things that six has
there hasn't that hasn't been brought
into the into the and then just a
sidelight you've got the warning with
the squiggly is because you have yours
yeah secrets buried in your code we did
in our episode on secrets and I won't do
that I always do that because I have to
hide my secrets alright so we did a
whole episode on that good good that's
awesome because that needs to happen so
we're gonna but you can leave it in
there for now if you what actually
unless you want to do it right now I can
just delete it
okay we're we're not gonna worry about
anymore because I'll show you how we we
take care of it but you may have already
shown in a previous episode but I'll go
through it again
first worth repeating that yeah
so we have this we have our generated
files now we're gonna go and we're gonna
work on our startup startup that C S is
the new core way of of kind of standing
up all of your services and doing your
dependency injection and stuff like that
so but first I'm gonna go to my app
settings that JSON so app settings that
JSON is is kind of like if you remember
the old web config mmm-hmm you can keep
a bunch of stuff in there
well app settings that JSON is a JSON
file that you can put stuff in there
that your your project can go out and
get so I just have some trusted code so
I can put my connection string out here
so in here I have connection strings and
then in underneath connection strings in
that in that area I should note DB and
then the same connection string that we
use to generate the files and all the
models in the DB con
same exact one now you could give it a
different one you could say you know
what I have Chinook running locally but
I also have Chinook running up in the
cloud and I generate it and they're both
the same and I want to point my actual
API is up in the cloud you can do that
check so it's just a connection string
but we're going to keep it local and now
we're gonna go over to startup and we're
going to go into configure services and
in here we're going to put in some more
code you can see I I don't like to type
I'm a little lazy so we're gonna put in
two lines of code so in here and you can
see we have some screws wiggly lines
let's fix those squiggly lines real
quick so we're gonna point two models to
get our Chinook context and then we need
to bring in the Microsoft at anything
framework core library okay for using
clauses so at this point we have a line
that says I have a connection string and
I'm going to go through configuration
get connection string and then it's
called Chinook DB and that's what we did
in app settings that JSON okay so we're
just leveraging something that's already
been given to us and in the
configuration object that that a speed
on that core gives you and then we're
just going to say we're gonna do
dependency injection and we're going to
say services our services we're gonna
inject our DB context and we're gonna
say add DB context it's of type of
Chinook context and then in there we're
gonna say options use sequel server and
then we're going to give it the
connection string okay so we are we are
building and setting up our dbcontext
at the very start of our of our project
and injecting it in so that everyone can
use it right and no one should be able
to get our connection string it's it's
pretty hidden and also if you send this
out to Azure Asher will overwrite it
through through the web app if you use a
web app service you can actually
overwrite that by having a setting by
putting a different connection string
and it will inject it into here without
you having the change in eco rack which
is very nice so at this point we have
our DB context it's been injected into
our into our application to be to be
used so let's go back over to the to the
DB context before I got rid of
everything and on configuring because I
don't need that anymore I've already set
up that connection string before I
injected it so that's why I don't really
need to have that in there anymore so so
at this point we're we're pretty good
the last thing that we need to do is
have our controllers right so I need to
know how we're gonna route these these
HTTP calls to the right controllers and
actions and those control rights okay
and this is really simple to deleted
that I didn't tell her because it was it
wasn't doing it wasn't so so let's take
a look so if I say add controller see
down here we have a API controller with
actions using yeah one of my favorite
features of all times it'll build a
controller for you yes yes for us lazy
people right well it will at least get
you get you the start less plumbing I
can write the
I want to focus on my business logic I
do I want to I want to focus on getting
something up and running and then and
then really customizing it to what I
want so model class we're just going to
go through a couple although I do think
there should be I continue to think
there should be the ability to do all of
them yeah so I work at JetBrains and we
have some tools like we have we sharper
and I'm actually building a plugin to do
that and then it's gonna go for a rider
which is our da Dada IDE but I can't say
that too much around the Microsoft world
around here well that work with Visual
Studio
it will work with resharper ok it won't
work with with but it will if you have
resharper mm-hmm installed it should
work with that so ok I'm actually
building it right now so and what that's
gonna do is it's gonna find just like
this does with the drop-down right it's
gonna find everything all these
different model classes yeah and I'll
tell you what if you write it as an
extension of Visual Studio I'll have you
on the show to show ya maybe I can run
this here and maybe I can write it also
at the attention so oh you should be
able to MIT should be that hard so I'm
gonna do album so album is a bottle
class in our in our API and then I'm
gonna say my data context class is that
Chinook context and then it will auto
generate the controller name and can
change it if you want but what you have
to remember is because NBC has some
convention you have to have the model
name controller kind of here I go the
plumbing is expecting us call them get
role or so it's easier just to leave it
that way otherwise you'd have to go mess
with the mess with the plumbing you have
to start really adding a lot of code to
start up and so now you're moving away
from your idea of focusing on yes
yeah the code that you need to write yes
yeah and you can do it but it yeah it it
takes a lot more
work and hoops to go through so so it's
setting up a controller let me close out
the models I open up the controller
folder so you can see that and in here
it actually set up our route for us so
remember we had API so it's API slash
controller you name whatever the
controller name which in this instance
it's going to be albums and it set up
everything that it needed it actually
has already set up the a internal
private read-only property for tional
contacts which on the constructor uses
dependency injection to get that context
and so everything can use its ok so we
don't even have to write any code to
connect our initially connect our
instructors or connect our controllers
to our DB contacts just now now for demo
purposes this is great I like right I
love this advance for production I don't
do it this way and we'll look at another
episode where we'll look at some more
advanced architectures but but for this
simple demo this is fine so we have a
command called get album and you can see
that they're all marked up with some
annotations so we have HTTP GET so the
one thing that differentiates a
controller from traditional MVC and one
thing that we use in web api's is that
we decorate our actions with these HTTP
verb attributes so so you can see that
we have HTTP GET down here when we want
to get a single album we have HTTP GET
and then it has an ID that comes along
with it we have a HTTP put so this will
do an update mm-hmm
we want to update an album we will we
will set up that annotation of HTTP put
and then we have a post so this will add
a new album to whatever data repository
that that we're using on a back-end
sequel server in our case and the last
one is HTTP delete so we're gonna use
those four we're gonna leverage those
four HTTP verbs right for this demo so
the scaffolding built your basic crud it
built pretty much everything that you
and then you if you have more advanced
data logic you can just swap out the
actual code in here
with whatever you want yep as long at
any framework six it's not nit core so
as long as you're writing code that's
supported by dotnet core not one and any
framework six you can do whatever you
want in here whether it's validation or
you're going to different places or
you're massaging the data whatever you
need to do you can put that code in here
and it does do some validation so let's
take a look at the post we do come in
here and it does check to see if if it's
valid if the - that's valid okay if it's
not it will send back it will return a
bad request so a bad request is a 404
mm-hmm so you can either you can there
are calls to send back you can send back
whatever response code HTTP response
code that you want but asp.net core has
a lot of these simple things that we can
do so if I want a bad request I can do
that if I want and okay I can do that if
I want some kind of 500 error there's a
there's a very verbose call to do that
or I can have just respond with specific
response code and then put my own my own
message right into it so it's it's quite
flexible but for this we're gonna leave
it for that now one thing I do want to
say you brought up the business logic so
I don't know if you're like me but I
don't like to delete data and my
databases
I like to deprecate it mhm so I like to
just have a bit that says like on/off
visible or not visible so you could come
in here into this delete album action
and instead of doing a remove down here
you could do an update right you could
just update that record yep and archive
it over there or whatever you want the
point is here that you can you have
control right that it wrote some nice
templated boilerplate code for you which
may be all you need or you can you know
call out to other services you can
whatever you want yeah so so let's add
one more controller because kind of have
to have I like to have at least two
controllers so let's go down here and
we'll we'll do artist so and it's
already set up it remembers the last the
last dbcontext that you so you don't
have to select that and we get we get
another one
now I'm gonna clear this out so we don't
see that red I'm gonna build this to
make sure it builds okay and then let's
see if it will run of course it'll run
why wouldn't it run it should it's my
least favorite word and all of
technology it should okay it should work
so we got a page can't be found which is
good because we actually haven't given
it a valid right so all we have up here
is localhost and then the port that
we're using and then slash API so if I
said albums because remember we set up
in albums controller and in there we had
a route that's
anything from API slash controller name
would come into their into that
controller into the corresponding action
and yeah they have and and I use a
add-in for Chrome that that makes my
JSON look fine so if if it looks like
this that you get if you're you get a
raw you of it don't worry it's it's fine
I just have it par so I can kind of see
okay and we have it so and if I want to
do let's say 42 is my favorite number so
if I want to say give me the album that
the album ID is 42 I just say albums
slash 42 and that route will go to the
get with an ID yeah and I get back I get
back album 42 so it's that simple
yep to set up your Web API project right
that's all you need to do it oh it's
really simple and then all you need to
do to call it is pass the correct string
yep
yup however your that gets done yeah and
and you can use a web browser mm-hmm but
you can't do anything other than a get
with a web browser so if you want to
test out and you want to try out your
api's there's a few different
applications that you can use I use that
learn or I use postman okay and they're
both free they're both free applications
that you can install locally postman
will run locally or through Chrome or
through I don't know if there's an edge
I don't know but but I just run it
locally and
I can call and I can say here's my
here's my string that I'm going to send
over and my verb and I can even set up
headers and my HTTP call to to set
things like authentication and stuff
like that so we're not even gonna look
at the all of that but there's a whole
rich experience around authenticating
around your web api's mhm and you can do
that yourself or there's third-party
companies in the in the partners
ecosystem that will that will allow you
to to wrap and help you out with your
authentication and now that you have
this API written tested proven you can
run it you know is locally you can
publish it up to Azure you can run it in
a container there's all kind of things
you can do yeah because it's asp.net
core I can run it on Mac OS yeah we're
Linux mhm I can like you said I can I
can run it on any number of different
instances of Adger yep so I can run it
on a web app that is of type Windows or
of type Linux yeah I can put it up in a
in a container and because Linux
containers are so cheap on Azure mm-hmm
it's perfectly fine the micro with ma up
on that kubernetes you can use it with
kubernetes so yeah you can do you can
put it just about anywhere so yeah so
there you go so it's that simple
it is simple it is you said earlier it's
easy to do I said prove it you proved it
yeah
also so I do want people if if I ask
anyone if you're gonna be using web api
learn a little bit about HTTP sure
absolutely
yeah right same thing if you're gonna oh
with xamarin if you know C sharp and
sam'l you can build mobile apps of
course you
but you need to learn about iOS and
Android you learn about the operating
system yeah you're gonna build web API
you need to learn some web stuff but
this seems like if you are coming from
more of a client-side world and you want
to start learning web stuff this seems
like a great place to start it is it is
it's I mean it's simpler I think it's
simpler than than MVC you don't have to
worry about views and you don't have to
worry about all that you're just
basically getting those those HTTP HTTP
calls right and sending up your
controller and then you can build
whatever logic you want to use more
advanced stuff you can use a repository
pattern to pull out your business logic
from your controller actions which I
don't suggest that you put your code
your business object directly into those
actions I build them into repositories
that I can that I put into other
projects so I can kind of share them and
can test them so the biggest reason why
I don't put everything into my
controllers is because of testable right
okay because I want my API calls and my
business object to be independent so I
can test and make sure that they're
working right independently cool so
we're gonna be using asp.net core mm-hmm
Web API and we're going to use a
different kind of testing yeah so we're
actually going to be testing our the
actual API s that we build okay so in
the previous episode I built an API that
had two entity types mm-hmm that we were
building api's against albums and
artists right we were using the Chinook
database demo database that Microsoft
created some years ago that I use for
all my demo ok well that and my baseball
database
right um but the baseball database
little complex the thing is gigantic it
is it's fun though but we're gonna use
Chinook we're just gonna take what we
had the project that we had from part
one and we're gonna use it for this you
need to build integration tests and
we're actually like I said we're gonna
actually hit our api's and we're gonna
call a use a HTTP call with a verb and
then we're gonna get a response back and
we're gonna make sure that that response
and the response code is what we expect
okay
and if we if it comes back as expected
the integration test passes okay and if
it doesn't it fails so this is
integration testing so the unit testing
would be inside the web api and now
we're saying that if from a client you
called the web api do you get the right
stuff back that's more that's an
integration test so I think you should
test external I agree with that
statement you should test you should
tell if it over and over again yep
and what we're going to be leveraging
and using the exact same coding styles
that you would use okay for internal
unit tests so we're gonna use X unit for
this okay
so we're not so you'll probably look at
this and go it looks just like my unit
tests that I build every day cool and
it's like yep it does it just tests
different things right and we'll explain
sweet okay so you can see I've got my
application I've got visual studio
running and it has a project in here
called Chinook core API this is the one
we built in the last episode same exact
code and so what we want to do is create
an additional project done on this
solution so we're gonna say and new
project and then we're going to come in
and under dotnet core we're gonna say X
unit test project now you can use MS
test I like actually
myself and in here we're going to give
it a name and I'm gonna I'd like to give
my my tests the same name that I give
the projects that they're testing so I'm
gonna say Chinook or API dot and for
this I'm gonna do integration testing or
integration tests because I will set up
two projects against a API against a Web
API project I will set up a integration
project integration testing project and
I'll set up a traditional unit testing
project okay
because I want to test overrides good
yeah so so for this I just call it and
you can name it whatever you want I just
call it the name of the project I'm
testing dot integration tests and we're
gonna say there it will stand up that
new project and pull in all the
dependencies the first thing you want to
do is say add reference and then we want
to allow so it pulled down X unit for
you yeah and now show the I'll show that
NuGet packages in a second because we
have to install some additional NuGet
packages ok but we want this integration
testing they have a reference back to
the to what its tests are right so we
just need to give it that reference so
that it knows what projects it has
reference to so we say that this
integration test is going to have a
reference back to the Chinook or API and
if I open up the dependencies and new
get you can see that we have a number of
different NuGet packages already
installed from this project template so
we have microsoft.net test SDK with
xunit and then we've got extra unit that
runner dot visual studio yep we need
some additional
NuGet packages to allow us to do
integration testing now I have that code
all up and running and I'm gonna install
them and then I walk through what those
are in here now let's go to package
manager console and this is a gotcha
I'll I get burned on this every time I
do this this default project always
defaults to the original project so it
will it will default to the Web API so
you want to make sure that you're
pointing that to your integration test
because we want to install those NuGet
packages with the integration test
project so I'm going to install
everything and then we'll take a look at
the packages that we that we installed
so the first one is and you can see it
just came in and it's being stood stood
up is Microsoft got asp.net dot or ASP
asp net core MVC dot MVC which most when
you do unit testing you're you don't
need all of that to be brought in but
well I'll explain why you need that for
for the for this type of testing and
then we also need Microsoft at asp net
core diagnostics and then the most
important one that we need is the
microsoft.net core dot test host and
that will allow your integration test to
stand up a hidden instance of your web
api project so that the tests can
actually hit it but it
actually doesn't bring it up in a
browser it kind of hides this kind of
cool so in the back rather than publish
the API and then call it from your
integration test you're basically
creating a local version that gets stood
up that you can call locally yeah and
it's kind of cool just a small it's a
small little host that giant hosts your
your API and it lives as long as your
test live right and when it's when the
tests are done it shuts it down and
expose of it okay so we have all of
those dependencies so we can hide that
just like I did in my previous project
in the previous video I'm gonna get rid
of this unit test one mm-hm
because one it doesn't really have
anything in there anyway and I like to
start out with a clean slate
so I'm gonna come in and I'm gonna add a
new add a new class
so for the time being I haven't really
found that any that anyone has created a
xunit
asp.net core unit test template at least
I haven't found anything here so I so I
have to I'm gonna create it myself so
I'm gonna call it album's integration
test dot CS you can name it whatever you
want
there's no convention for the naming of
these so I'm gonna say add and I'm going
to go out and get my trusted code and
I'm gonna bring in a few things so the
first thing that I'm going to have is
and let me fix these uh so we can see
everything just make sure that we bring
in those those using clauses so so what
we have here is we have two private
read-only properties and one is up type
HTTP client and one is a type test
server so our tests have to have both we
have to have a client we have to have a
server the client makes the HTTP call
and then the server does the work and
sends back the response again this is
cool because you don't have to take the
time to write a client exactly yes the
server yeah so right we're lazy people
like me this is perf your job is to just
to write the API why do you need to
write a client yeah and I don't want to
I don't want to spend weeks building now
my unit tests right and as I'm showing
here it's really easy to build these
unit tests and use this these built-in
client and servers mm-hmm okay so let's
go on to our next piece pieces of code
and
I'm gonna come in and uh maybe that
misspelled come on okay okay let's fix
this for the web hosting builder so this
just comes in and it's under hosting so
this constructor that I just brought in
stands up and creates the server and the
client properties so what we're saying
is server is a new test server and we
give it a new instance of web host
builder and what we're what we give that
West web host builder is we call a you
startup and if you take a look that
startup is actually the class from our
Web API project right and because that
startup is what asp.net uses to stand
out and get all your services and
everything up and running for your for
your asp.net project and then the
clients is a client that's that's
generated off of the server because the
client needs to know everything about
the web api right and the server knows
all about itself because it actually has
this it's API
internally mm-hmm so we generate that
client and it already knows all the
calls they they can do so we don't even
have to to stand up and tell the client
here are all the api's here are all the
the the the verbs that go along with
those api's and here's all the
parameters that you can call it just
stands it up and we're good to go
cool okay so the next piece of code is
our tests now I'm going to bring in the
first test and walk through that so so
here is a tab
we're going to fix this so we it
references actually met okay and I'll we
need to fix that because HTTP status
code uses system nets and tasks uses
another reference so we're all good so
okay so this first test is we're going
to test to see if we get the entire
payload returned back to us with all
albums of the all album API call and you
can see that in here we have in line
data which is a X unit attribute that we
can decorate this this test with and we
give it the verb that we're going to use
and that gets sent in to this method
which it gets used with this HTTP
request message no crater and so this
message this request message has to know
two things it has to know the verb and
the string that gets sent over mm-hmm
and that string that gets sent over is
AP / API / albums because the client
already knows the base URL right
it's localhost colon some port all we
need to do is give it the the segment
that's different from the base URL and
that's just this / API / albums so
that's our arrange part of our test
now we need to act on the test and what
we're gonna do is take that request and
we're going to send it through the
client to the server so we we say under
sort client that send asynchronously the
request that we just created and then
we're gonna wait to get the response
back from our test host which is running
our web api project and then down in our
assert we're going to first say that we
want to ensure a successful status code
so so a successful success status code
is I'm quizzing you what is the status
code what's it's okay what's uh what's
you hundred two hundred yes I set you up
with a softball so we're gonna make sure
that that response can't wait that one's
yeah so we're kind of doing a double
assert I want to show two different ways
that we can check to see if that if that
return status code is successful so you
can use response that ensure success
status code and then you can say assert
that equal and then you can just say the
response status code is equal to and
what you're testing here you're not
testing the data that comes back I can
you can but you're not doing that here
simple task
right you're just saying if I call this
will it tell me it worked
yes and this is a simple test yeah so I
could make more advanced integration
tonight I could say and we'll take a
look at that but with us without this
this is so cool because you don't have
to go to the browser and start typing
things which then every time you do it
you have to go to the browser and start
typing things you've also done this in
fiddler yeah again you can go in and and
enter the URL string whatever now in
fiddler herb and see that it works yeah
but that's kind of a one-off here it's
more permanent you can run these
integration tests over and over and over
again yeah and I can load all these
tests up intense continuous integration
right yes automate it yeah I completely
so cool my local servers and it can be
run every time any time someone checks
in code for this Web API right solution
in our project all of these
integration tests can be run to make
sure if I hit this from the outside or
all my api's correct yep
and if something blows up I can I'll
probably I'll get an error code back
with some kind of message and that will
alert someone and then it should break
something running some unit tests yeah
also so I can say oh well
calling all albums broke and then also
here's where I think the unit tests that
failed correspondence about and you can
also as part of the integration test
pass bad data
yeah and confirm that you get a not only
100 400 400 or sighs oh yeah right yeah
you can you can write test it when you
call it correctly it doesn't work I can
test it for anything I can tested for
the 300 level response codes again I can
do whatever I want
very cool okay let's take a look at one
more unit test and this one is a way
that call to send over an additional
property into your test so you can see
up here I have an inline data it's using
the get verb and I send over a one so
that one corresponds with an ID on the
on this method and so I just say ID
equals one and then I build my my HTTP
call string to use that ID so I say
slash API slash album slash whatever I
sent in for my ID and I go through the
same thing now I could set up an assert
that says that checks to see if the ID
that I'd sent in through this method
equals the ID that I get back from the
response in the JSON payload
I can't ask you that - yeah but you more
likely have that be part of the unit
test of the code I could I could test
because you could do a unit test well
also if I build all my unit tests right
right I'm calling all of those
controller actions right individually
writing unit tests anyway right so in
all I'm really testing here is to make
sure that if I ping something from the
outside it that is working right I said
so the integration test is gonna is this
a correct statement the integration test
will typically leaning more towards
assuming that if I call this service
right I'm assuming that it runs
correctly and it's been tested correctly
it's gonna send me stuff back am I
getting back what I expect yeah now yep
and then to make sure that the service
itself does the things that are correct
it's really kind of the services job to
do that the person to remove that so you
might I would expect the unit tests on
the service to cover that you know and
this integration test to cover
yeah what happens when I call the
service from the client well and it's I
really install in bed so think about I
build it so that every layer from the AP
from the external API point back so
controllers and then maybe some
middleware and then going all the way
back to my enemy framework we're
positing framework core repository right
that actually are doing the the call and
the retrieval beta which then gets sent
forward everything is being tested right
so everything should kind of ripple
forward and something breaks it's gonna
break all the way it's something broken
my all the way back in my any of the
framework core layer in my data layer
using my repositories it should break
all the way through mm-hm
so it just will prove that that it does
break or it breaks somewhere in the
middle and I can see where along that
path
it broke right cool but I just wanted to
show because a lot of times people don't
have never seen this type of test yes
integration test and you can add
integration tests for the for the put
post and delete as well and it's that
and it's actually working with the real
live data this is okay but you can send
it up you could mock it you could mock
it right in the back end okay right you
could set up in the other which you
probably I don't obably want to do if
you're gonna run yes so if you're gonna
run integration tests on on CI every
time you check in code you get it tests
around of course then your integration
test run and then I would heart of Wix
or even in your unit testing you're
inserting updating deleting you know
into the real database you probably want
to do that as part of your test
especially since you don't let anybody
delete from the database I don't even
have a bunch of bogus records that are
in there right or I have a bunch of
records that are turned off but I would
have to go back in see either mock or
you be able to flip back and forth you
know fourth put in a test database which
might get emptied out and redone yeah
although there's overhead with that or
you might just mock it but that's the
beauty of all this Sharon can do what
you want right so for this test I'm just
showing how we actually do the
integration test and we're just going
against a local database cool so it's
one more tool that you can put in your
tool belt yep or in a tool box or is it
where box
yes exactly
you have another testing - yes right on
yeah cool so we're now two out of three
done in episode three you're gonna teach
us some best practices from your on how
to do this better in real life hopefully
that's my goal that's a promise to it to
show all the scars I have and what I do
excellent ok so let's talk about what
you and I do wrong because I only have
30 minutes yeah yeah so we're gonna have
to work through this
so bad habit so what kind of bad habits
do we have you know in the first video
that we showed we were doing all of our
data access from controllers we're right
in the actions mm-hmm well that's a bad
it's kind of code behind some acts of
code behind yeah yeah it really does it
really smacks of of cramming all your
code into one area and then you're kind
of locked in right so don't do that even
though we showed on the demo don't do it
for your production code I say don't
have all your code in a single project
okay one it's hard to test two if you're
in a big team you won't step on people's
toes and if you update one project it
may not and you go through CI continuous
integration and building out on the
server it minimizes the work that those
DevOps systems have to do right and then
we don't want a couple the data access
which in our case is anything framework
or to our project domain knowledge and
I'll explain that okay once we take a
look at some of the layers and once we
take a look at the code and then we we
don't want to forget and another bad
habit is people don't think about unit
testing and integration testing or they
don't do it they think about how they
should do it but they don't do enough of
yeah
and you should build your solutions
build your systems so that with testing
in mind
mm-hm right absolutely yeah because if I
build it in a way that I can't test
everything excuse me then it's a failure
mm-hmm okay so you guys think about unit
testing and integration
testing so how I build my API is I have
this triangle in this case but I have
four different areas I look at I have my
API which just handles the actual API
that people call so it really contains
all my controllers and my actions knows
correspond to my two entities in this
case using using this architecture and
the actions correspond to different
verbs that we can do against those those
entity types okay so with the schnook
database we have like albums and artists
as an example and we can do things like
get all of our artists or get all of our
albums or get mm-hm
one or delete or update or insert new
new entities so that's all the API
should do then we take a look at domain
and domain is kind of the heart of my
architecture it really does it's where
all the business logic lives it's where
all the validation lives okay it's it's
really the the center and that's why
it's in the center of this this triangle
or pyramid and then data I mean you need
to have some some way to get data even
the very mocking way I still have you
have to have data access to get yeah
send back your mock data well in this
case data in a production sense is where
I have all of my entity framework core
logic mm-hmm and I separate it because I
want to be able to test all I want to be
able to test my api's and my domain
against production database and mock
grant database or a mock data access my
mock data and then the last one is test
mm-hm which are important don't forget
about tests you have to have your test
projects that go along with your
everything else so we'll quickly go
through what each layer should be so so
API layer
like a UI of a asp.net MVC project the
API endpoints should not know anything
about domain knowledge or dead or the
dead access all it should know is how to
get those HTTP calls mm-hm and how to
respond back yep from those so it's it's
a view the view doesn't know about the
view model do you he doesn't know the
exact but the model right exactly
it should interact with view models to
ensure the greatest flexibility now now
we were talking about this earlier and
I'm going to use an example and my
Chinook database there's a entity called
invoice and invoices are made up of
multiple invoice lines right but we
don't know the total of the total amount
of an invoice unless we know all of the
invoice lines right individual costs and
so in most databases in my databases I
don't save the total amount for an
invoice I'd calculate that right on the
fly so if you take a look at a one side
we have our data models that are based
one the one on on the tables in our
database on the other side I've got
these view models and how do I convert
how do I take a invoice data model
instance and convert it so it has a
total property right inside of it it has
to go through my domain layer and figure
out all of the individual invoice lines
total those up insert that into a
property in the corresponding view model
and then vice versa when a view model
comes in from my API and I don't have
and I have a total maybe I use it to
verify that that totally equals all of
the corresponding
invoice line rolled up total hmm so I
use it for validation coming from the
other way right so that's why I a P I
only deals with view models it doesn't
know anything about data the data models
domain layer contains both my entity
models my data models and my view models
okay so because it needs to do the
conversion right it contains all of my
interfaces for my data retrieval so I
can keep a well-defined standard for all
my data access now what I mean about
what I mean by that is that if I have
two different ways that my API can get
data meaning maybe I get it from sequel
server and that's in one project and
then I have another project for my mock
data I each one of those needs to know
the interfaces that they have to adhere
to what the contracts so to say and so
my domain layer contains all of my
contracts that my data access projects
have to adhere to mm-hmm because if they
don't then they won't they won't work
well or they won't work at all right so
all my interfaces are in my domain layer
and then this also allows me to use
dependency injection for my repositories
okay so those those repositories that
live in those individual data access
projects can be injected into my domain
layer so if they're coming from
repositories that use any framework or
or use the mock my mock access mock data
access the domain layer doesn't care it
doesn't even it really doesn't it
doesn't no no sure and then I think of
my domain layer it's a supervisor and
it's actual there's a actual class
called supervisor that does all the
heavy lifting in their data layer pretty
simple it's where all
heavy data lifting happens everything
that it does is defined based on
interfaces from domain layer we talked
about that and in my sample architecture
instance I use in a framework or 2.1 but
you can use anything that adheres to dot
that standard 2.0 okay okay and then I
also use mock for for testing up a data
access layer for testing and then my
tests I have two types of test
integration that we looked at in
previous video and traditional unit
testing which we cover fully with my
series with filter pixie exactly and so
this is integrated for API endpoint
testing and controllers so we also test
out our api's and the controllers that
are in the api's and then we cover all
of our unit tests for our repositories
and our individual data access layers
you can test out really you should be
testing a lot more than I then I show in
my in my sample okay and that's it
alright so so let's dig in and show let
see the sample yeah let's dig in and
show the sample okay so let's first take
a look at the different project so if I
collapse all these down and just show
the different projects that we have
there are a number of different projects
like I said we have Chinook dot API now
I I sent up a naming convention for my
projects where I have a base name and
then a dot and then whatever it
corresponds to so I should note that API
should note that domain she looked at
data she looked at integration tests
mock data so I have to so my mock data
adheres to the same interfaces as my
Chinook that data and then I have
integration tests
and then I have unit tests in here I saw
the MS unit test because my unit tests
are all X unit and I try to to make sure
that that I'm gonna be running some some
MS unit tests for people that that like
that library for testing okay
so I try not to be biased and and on and
and just like at one side so the first
thing I want to take a look at and I'm
gonna I'm gonna close all these
documents is I want to take a look at my
API now in my API I'm gonna show my
startup and I'm gonna make this small so
in here I recommend and you don't have
to do this but I recommend not putting
all all of my configuration stuff into
my startup so if you see here I have a
bunch of these like configure
repositories and configure supervisor
and add middleware and my cores which
we've never talked about but I have all
these things that I want to do that I
want to inject and stand up for my
services but I don't want my configure
services to be this gigantic method so
if you take a look out here under
configurations I have a some classes
that handle all those and let's take a
look at like configuring connections so
I have an add connection provider call
that basically goes out and gets the
connection string from my app settings
that JSON and it just sets that up adds
that DB contacts injects that dbcontext
into my project and then returns it and
and for me am I thinking
it it is better for me to push all these
stuff out so that I know what I'm
working with instead of having this
gigantic method so so that's one kind of
best practice that I do in this
Kotetsu if i go back to my startup I
also use swagger yeah no you know
Swagerty but in this and this project is
out on my github republic ow so it's a
it's a repository that we'll probably
linked to in the yes in the episode
notes but we use swagger for them and
Swagger's really simple swagger is kind
of a human readable form has a UI to it
so you can actually kind of see what
you're working with
right and we'll show it at the end of
the end of this video it's kind of cool
you can see how that's set up you can
see how I do
cores and and also some other things but
don't mind dwell too deep let's take a
look at controllers because my
controllers are dumb they're very dumb
so so this is a album controller and
this is a get all so this is a action to
get all albums so all I do in here is
I'm really just calling this Chinook
supervisor which was using depending
injection was was injected into this
project and if I take a look up here in
the constructor I just grabbed that that
Chinook supervisor assign it to an
internal private property on this
controller and I can use it and I just
call get all album async so I'm using
I'm using async calls all over the place
so that I'm not kind of hurting the
performance on API and if I catch an
exception coming back from from that I
send back a status code of five hundred
in this example you could be more you
can get more than
and fancy and do different things but
for this example all I want to know is
did I get some kind of internal error
behind the controller action mm-hmm if I
did I send back a 500 meaning I I made
the mistake a 400 is you made the
mistake okay
I made the mistake so I'm gonna send
backup 500 and then I'm gonna send back
the exception which will allow the
person getting that response back just
to get some kind of information right
about the exception that handled that
that occurred and that's all I'm doing
I mean if you take a look at all all of
this it's really kind of kind of simple
all my controller actions are very
simple like if I want to get a specific
ID a specific album from the from the
corresponding data access whatever it is
I come in and I check to see if if that
album exists so that if it doesn't exist
in my in the in the database I send back
and not found okay and that's a 404
right right yeah if I if everything gets
sent back okay I send back in okay with
the response with that one album to be
sent back if I catch an exception I sent
back a status code of 500 okay that this
is all really my my actions do my
controllers Dre they just get they call
out to to my supervisor to get
information to get data to get
information and then they send it back
out or send back some error or some kind
of other response code so really that's
all my API project does right simple so
now let's take a look at the data side
okay of the solution so the data side is
actually really simple also it's just
data access that's all we're doing we
don't we don't
about validation or making sure that the
data is correct we just get it and send
it back so we really just have these
repositories so we're using the
repository pattern to to make to have
all these calls and they really just
correspond to to certain things like we
can we have a call that says album
exists so it just goes out and says does
this ID exist in the in the database
yeah and then we have like get all async
and get get by ID async and add a sync
and I mean our crud is right forward
stuff yeah it's just straightforward EF
stuff and it's it's really basic stuff
okay okay
so so we're still doing kind of boring
stuff so but let's get into the domain
now so let's close that out our domain
is little interesting so so we we keep
all of our stuff in here so when I
created and generated my entity models
mm-hmm they actually got created in the
data access layer but I actually pulled
them out because all of my data all of
my data access my Mac and my my sequel
server have to adhere to the same the
same entity model right right so I
wanted to keep them separated from from
each one of my data access layers so I
keep them in my my domain so that
everyone can reference them and they're
referencing the same classes they don't
have different classes and someone could
go in and modify one end of the class
and one project it would break the other
one and break the whole thing break the
whole thing I also have my few models
which correspond to what I'm interacting
with with the API and they're these the
same view models that you would right
now
application yeah it's the same
corresponding I mean they're just I mean
and they almost look exactly alike so if
I take a look at album mm-hmm
you can see album was made up of an
album ID a title and an artist ID yeah
but what if I wanted an album to also
have the artist name included in it so
this example where I have a view model
that is has a slightly different shape
okay so this is a different view model
than the view model teeth have an mvvm
view model and mvvm does the actual data
manipulation yeah so there's always okay
dad this is just this is just basically
giving me the shape that I want to work
with in my own eyes alright so you can
see that the only thing that's really
different between the two is really in
this I've inserted a artists name into
my view model so that I want when I send
back and someone says give me all the
album's that were that we're created by
or maybe if I had some kind of date on
this maybe I could say give me all the
album's that were created in 1979 right
or produced in 1971 all Dave Matthews
albums sometimes it's Dave Matthews
sometimes it's Dave Matthews Band right
yeah exam Matthews
sure so we've got that so that's just an
example why I have entity models and
view models is because sometimes I want
different stuff to be to work with the
api's right so if we also we have our
repositories and these are just our
interfaces okay so that's why I keep all
of my interfaces in this domain so that
that makes all of my data access have to
adhere to these contract right okay and
the last two are I have my supervisor
which is just one gigantic class I don't
really like it
but I couldn't get away from having a
bunch of circular reference issues so I
have one gigantic I call it the Chinook
supervisor and it gets injected all of
the repositories that I'm working with
so you can see here that in the
constructor I get back all of the
repositories from whatever data access
project I'm working with either the Mach
1 or the anything framework core 1 and
it uses those repositories to do certain
things like if I say get all album async
I basically get all of my I call that
corresponding repository and say give me
back all my albums mm-hmm and then I
convert that list over to view models
and I have a bunch of converters that
convert over now ok now I could use
other third-party tools that that do
that conversion automatically mhm but I
did converters just to show people what
you could do right so so in the end and
then I convert them and I don't really
even need to do this anymore
I thought I got rid of all these but but
really all the supervisor does is come
it converts one side to the other
either converts view models to entity
models or enemy models to view models
because I'm done I tend to put that code
in my view model in case your cards yeah
it's kind of a clunky but I do it and I
could put some validation I'm gonna be
wearing I liked the idea of separating
that out because you know the the view
model is retrieving data and preparing
it for the view right but so ever view
so yeah I call the view model I maybe I
should call it like an API model maybe
yeah
so so maybe I'm not calling it the right
thing I'm calling it something to
distinguish it from the rain but even
when it in in zamel apps when it
literally is the view model I like the
idea of the view model calls out to
something which goes and gets the data
and then does the manipulation passes it
back to the view model which then turns
around of the view and said here's your
data with album with artist title
attached to invoice already calculated
instead of having that code living in
the view model so retrieve the data from
the database and then do the the
conversions I break out all that because
because I can I can build unit test
against a supervisor yeah object and I
can build unit testing heads to convert
yes and I can it separates the the
concerns if if you change the way you do
the conversions it's all in one place
exactly okay yeah I like that so that's
really my domain mm-hmm and I can also
show you my mock data my mock data looks
almost like my my data that uses any of
the framework
it just has really simple repositories
in this I just create one for like get
call way sing for for album I'm just
hand coding one album mm-hmm and then I
send it back now I know you there's more
advanced as you probably saw with Phil
there's more advanced ways to do mocking
this is just a simple way that one
people can can see just how to do it
right we use basic sense mock cue or mo
shocker mock you or you or whoever your
person there's tons of ways to do it
this is just a simple way that I'm just
sending back one one thing and it's just
a bare bone as basic as it can get okay
so and would I do this for production no
for like a real production API knowing
this is just a demo okay
and then again as you've seen in the in
the last video this is the same exact
thing that we were doing before with
integration testing you can go back and
take a look at that video
get your unit tests in there is good and
I have and then I have unit tests down
below where I in this example I just
unit test my repositories and these
actually go out and unit test the mock
the mock data access ok because I some
of these tests I check to see how many
how many instances entity instances I'm
returning there so I really want that
done in a in a work environment you know
what attacks the database you don't want
to spin up as your charges you don't
want to have necessarily have an entire
mock database you know yeah you should
be able to to test based on my data and
and that's really it that's my
architecture okay so it just comes back
to I try to decoupled as much stuff as I
can from each other I tried to break it
down into smallest pieces mm-hmm so one
I can understand them because like I
said I'm not super smart so I have to
break everything down into small chunks
so I can keep organized everything in my
brain and I can test each individual
place all my gears can be tested without
any other information around yeah and
that's it very cool yeah so so so like I
said in the beginning this is just my
way of doing it I when I do talks I do
this talk around this architecture quite
a bit out in the community I would say
and I get people to come up to me and go
well why don't you do this and why don't
you do this and I and I take their
suggestions and I and I'll build them
back in in this I've had quite a few
little suggestions and
how to tweak things and make things
better so like I said I don't know
everything I'm just showing you what
I've learned over the years right and
try to kind of give a little wisdom out
to to people cool yeah all right
so I think this went really well yeah
this our series on doing Web API we saw
how to build them we saw had a testimony
saw how to architect them that's awesome
thanks so much for doing this
yeah thank you hope you guys enjoyed
that and we will see you next time on
visual studio toolbox